يا حيه ضيف الله على ما قسم الله
يا حياك الله
[موسيقى]
لذه الاكل اليد بدون
معلقه
[موسيقى]
انا في اشجار في ورد شجر في 48 في يعني
الهواء نقي يعني
[موسيقى]
في الاماكن اللي زي هيك انت ممكن تقعد
نهار كامل وبامكانك كمان انك تبات وكل شيء
موفر لك وانك بتلتمس التراث الفلسطيني في
هذا الموضوع انه انت عمالك بتشتغل على شغل
تراثي بحت اكلات تراثيه بحته فعلا احنا
بنحتاج انه يكون في عنا كتير من الاماكن
اللي زي هيك في قطاع
[موسيقى]
بشوف ابن نسيم انه هي فعلا بتاكد على قوه
المراه وثبات المراه وحضور المراه وفي كل
المجالات وبالذات في اماكن زي كذا منطقه
خطره او منطقه قريبه جدا من الشريط
الحدودي انه ام ياسين تعمل هيك
قعده او هيك يعني مكان عن جد كثير رائع
مرعى الفلسطينيه هي الوحيده الاكثر شيء
بتتعب بتتعب في جميع نساء العالم
[موسيقى]